è la madonna ei sawyer ceriale a che
serve un facehugger quando già the
perennemente col fiato addosso
grazie dio cioè un t rex poi ci
mancavano solo i dinosauri posa
bisognosa riposa keep out fosse entrato
dentro perfetto a questo è il video
amico dell'altro ti piace fare la
guardia notturna in realtà sostituisco
mio cugino giusto per questa notte
se nella detto hai di fronte a te il
campione nazionale in carica di gara di
insulti nel caso non lo sapesse niente e
nessuno batte la mia lingua tagliente
dimostramelo allora ma che fa perché
guardaroba il popolamento a netflix è
stato hackerato che signori hanno anche
figli a grandezza naturale
finirai per prendere una brutta postura
forza di restare recluso sempre meglio
che assomigliare a quel tuo brutto muso
a deve rispondere in rima i tuoi
genitori hanno anche figli a grandezza
naturale attaccare la mia altezza non
trovi nulla di più originale mai un nome
particolarmente brutto se fossi in te
eviterei di dirlo a ralph spaccatutto
tutto quel caffè finirà per ammazzarti
almeno mi dà l'energia per continuare
insultati il tuo abbonamento a netflix è
stato hackerato minchia poverino sta
morendo regalo che avevo messo in
guardia ma non mi ha voluto dar retta va
bene adesso posso passare nei punti
senza che mi rompa le palle immagine
posso quindi entrare nei posti o ma cece
della gente guarda e dalla gente fake
però marionette che si muovono solo fare
bomba innescata quanta roba guarda
sapere prendi la a cosa ti serve una
bomba faraone
sembra che stia aspettando qualcuno sono
in attesa che uno dei miei innumerevoli
spasimanti trovi finalmente il coraggio
di farsi avanti e cosa dovrebbe
trattenerli da farlo esattamente quello
che mi chiedo anch'io
temo che siano tutti troppo intimoriti
dalla mia bellezza e il fardello
dell'essere troppo belli se fatti anche
a me non mi caga nessuno sa perché sono
troppo figo
vorrei solo trovare una brava mummia con
cui passare il resto dei miei millenari
giorni non dovrebbe essere poi così
difficile in fondo non infierire fuori
alle balle andiamo dal tizio che che era
tornato a dipingere i muri di prima
perfetto
[Musica]
qualcuno mi spiega che problemi a questo
vabbè che facciamo prosciutto procedono
i preparativi diavolaccio siamo ormai a
un passo dal fare un sacco di soldi ma
perché hanno iniziato a dipingere gli
alieni spiega mi ero dimenticato di
precisare che non avrei raccolto quindi
posso inchiostra hryo con l'assenzio non
credo che così facendo con il
peperoncino l'assenza di con cina e
peperoncino e basta non ce l'ho
inzuppato già la pegno questo nella
piazza chiaro senza dubbio concentrato
di capsaicina il livello di capsaicina
all'interno è una cosa andava bene
dentro i sali tratto entro dentro al
bagno schiuma potresti mettere vai e sta
facendo un bagno data 20 anni
se esistono momenti trash su youtube
questo è uno di quelli
posso girare la manovra ma adesso ho
preso con il telone va bene tieni o una
lettera da parte del signor il signor
del signor muto che dolce batuffolo
dipende mi chiari cisl arel e penso che
accetterò la sua proposta
saltiamo pure i convenevoli dell'anello
di fidanzamento non ho tempo da perdere
ciò anche quelli tanto e hai portato le
fedi nuziali assolutamente gay o come le
fedi mia reggina cosa fai ancora lì
impalato trova giu un sacerdote per
celebrare le nozze
veramente mi sembra di aver fatto già
abbastanza è un ordine terremo la
cerimonia sopra il meteorite del
laghetto roswell che location romantic
lo trovo io il sacerdote show gesù nella
festa andiamo la festa senza figlio di
dio
visto che una delle superstar del creato
mi chiedevo se potesse celebrare il
matrimonio di un mio amico
beh alla fine sono il titolare di tutto
quel franchising di cappelle e chiese e
cattedrali varie che è meglio di me
giusto sono solo un po troppo sbronzo
avrei bisogno di un piccolissimo aiuto e
quindi potrebbe aiutare facciamo prima
proprio quello che mi ci voleva
ci vediamo al matrimonio allora ma non
sa nemmeno dove si celebra fratello sarò
pure sbronzo ma resto pur sempre
onniscienza a dopo va bene poi si fa
andare al laghetto dove sta la ghetta
aiuto questo laghetto per i poteri da
mio padre con fenomeno la mummia e molla
gare
[Musica]
che si era fatto un cazzo state a casa
ad aggiornare il vostro status
sentimentale su facebook
se sto vedendo rega quando trash che se
non si sta roba non merita like non lo
so farlo signori pare chiudere al posto
di o la vita credi di far paura a
qualcuno conciato così neppure una mosca
che ne so io però lenzuolo proprio mela
me l'ha buttato via ca nanna spaventa le
due ragazzini qui fuori prevenire due
ragazzini qui fuori mi prendono in giro
qualcuno tratta male il mio piccolo
ronnie mocciosi non ti preoccupare
tesoro mio
adesso ci pensa la nonna
[Musica]
cosa sto vedendo rai e anche mia nonna
spaventava i miei amici con i piatti di
pasta però è un casino tardi dovevi
proprio vedere le loro padri
le ho viste è stato fighissimo norma
grazie petardi bene c'è un sacco di
miniciccioli cosa me ne faccio anche una
bomba disinnescata e adesso questo è
successo non ha sbagliato a non sapevo
potevamo ok sarà vano fatta a caso ma la
bomba case perché qualcuno non mi scambi
per un kamikaze
posso svegliare il nonno si vai fermati
un secondo gomito di ragnatela vai punta
ci tutto bomba carica ad appiccicano
appiccicato rai pensato di far esplodere
tutto no povera nonna
let's go to the paris corriere espresso
24 ore 7 giorni su 7
potrei impacchettare l'armadio e
spedirmi alla nuova casa di roman
fantastico bastava leggere questo 0084 5
8901 bene 0084 5 non me lo ricordo sia
più che tende a ma sta facendo le
porcate lega la parola e la mummia va
bene sa mito del maschio né poi dna sta
pian tutto sto casino per st pianta
maledetta mai spacca guarda cosa qui per
te ti ha fatto il verso sincado
salute è la legge del più forte
ragazzaccia prova a usare il ritratto
hai visto alla fine a prendermi per gli
archi e aprirla quando si può
semplicemente sradicarla mani nude dal
suo blocco di cemento
non ho idea di quale possa essere la
combinazione massima affan cuore
perfetto mai è venuto in mente neppure
per un momento che qualcuno potrebbe
sentire il botto dell'esplosione
chiamare la polizia ma tu devi sempre
trumper e le palle per qualsiasi cosa
spiega me tappatevi le orecchie tutti lo
morite 28 giorni su you're tappatevi le
orecchie ma c'è casino non sentono
quando il mondo si alza il volume alza
il volume pezzo di deficiente vai
potresti aumentare la musica a tutto
volume
perché il dj è un alieno perfetto casi
l'incredibile ok theory adesso sarebbero
cioè non si sono i secondi dovrebbero
bastare via via levati dalle palle
però se casinò offline i davanti a porta
perfetto va beh
fiducioso il tipo ancora ubriaco tra
l'altro forse ho esagerato con la
polvere da sparo a bestie ghazi prendi
tutto prende i soldi
c'è anche un playbook le banconote
playbook va bene o delle dei soldi
adesso più si usava cabina del telefono
giustamente cioè se in filo alle
banconote nnamaka via del telefono posso
chiamare qual era il numero
il numero era 00 ricordo ormai 845 8901
e fila dei soldi nella bocchetta credevo
che la forma della bocchetta fosse
abbastanza autoesplicativa in ogni caso
ti aiuto va a monete è come li cambio
che c'è una banca
c'è una banca me lo spieghi tu non c'è
una banca in città si sblocca una città
oppure posso fare sempre la solita roba
di prima 100 anni dietro nel tempo
diventano saldi ci metto le banconote
nel calderone fatto che le ha messe
torna indietro diventano centesimi pieno
un'opera ce lo giuro a mele diventare
sordi giusti l'ha detto nel tempo poi li
prendi le monete che diventano sorti
quelli grossi i soldi piccoli scusami
soldi grossi erano quelli di prima
dietro tanto mi servono i soldi per la
macchinetta a posto quindi va dalla
macchinetta del telefono e chiamo il
numero che non mi ricordo assolutamente
84 58 901
mi chiamo ricordo vado a memoria
completamente anni prima di inserire le
monete andrebbe alzato la cornetta tu
sai quante volte nella mia vita ho usato
una cabina del telefono
neanche una alza la cornetta 0084 5 8901
mi cosa 84 58 54
[Musica]
è sbagliato buttato angelo corrieri
espresso come posso esserle utile
buonasera vorrei effettuare la
spedizione di una cassa funebre in via
venerdì 13 spese a carico del
destinatario è al corrente delle nostre
condizioni generali di impacchettamento
mi dica pure per evitare di riportare
danni durante il trasporto e richiediamo
di avvolgere l'oggetto con del materiale
che a tutti ska gli urti solitamente
della plastica da imballaggio ma può
servirsi della soluzione che preferisce
se non c'è alcun problema
e per finire è necessario identificare
il pacco con una scritta che ne indichi
chiaramente il contenuto si mike do la
soluzione
mi scusi non credo di avere sentito bene
si diceva
nessun problema le faccio arrivare
immediatamente il corriere per la sua
spedizione
la ringraziamo per aver scelto la nostra
compagnia arrivederci citazioni a mike
bongiorno va bene il corriere arriverà
fra poco sarà meglio impacchetta come lo
impacchetta che ha ben da kit di
imballaggio va bene sto aspettando un
corriere per portarvi all'armadio non è
che potresti impacchettarli c
all'interno con questo kit devo fare un
bello scherzetto amico sono sempre
pronto a dare una mano per questo genere
di cose come vorrei poter vedere la sua
faccia non riesco a immaginare che
spavento si prenderà neppure io credimi
a me tutto questo bordello tutti gli
episodi per spostare un armadio
c'è poi non avete idea tutto sto casino
per sposto certo capitato in corriere ip
ma mi avvio anche bel pacco va bene
[Musica]
totali faith grain lo sto vedendo la
ecco infatti era quello che mi aspettavo
però un'altra ronald svegliati
ma è morto ronaldo sono io skinny
davvero non mi riconosci ricordi io e te
insieme alla conquista del mondo
continuavano a ripeterci che eravamo
destinati a grandi cose ma amy in un
certo senso è stato così anche se
nessuno poteva immaginare tutto questo
non potevi sapere della mia allergia
persino io non ero a conoscenza in fin
dei conti ci sono un sacco di vantaggi a
essere morto o un'infinità di tempo
libero posso mangiare tutto ciò che
voglio senza dovermi preoccupare della
linea sono persino immune
all'elettricità neppure fosse un
supereroe l'altro landi sta dicendo
niente dove mi dispiace che tu abbia
sofferto tanto so quanto è stata dura
per te da quel giorno ma non hai nulla
da rimproverarti credimi
io non ho nulla da rimproverarsi non
riusciva a respirare mi sentivo soltanto
urlare non fu difficile capire cosa
stava per accadere ma incredibilmente
quella è l'ultima cosa che ricorda
nessuna luce da seguire nessuna
esperienza extracorporea solo un grande
nulla un po deludente non credi quando
finalmente mi sono svegliato era tutto
buio ci mise un po a realizzare di
essere in un armadio in questo armadio
lo so è davvero assurdo ma è la verità
sono stato riportato in vita e ora sono
uno scheletro devi tornare a parlare se
non di raja qualcuno quello che è
successo quel giorno finirai per essere
dannato in eterno è per questo che sono
qui perché ti voglio bene romano skinny
o per due ma se i capelli non gli
invidio per niente skinny aspetta non
andare
[Musica]
and magic hands che the wardrobe
progetto italiano fatto un culo così ai
progetti esteri direi perché la cosa
fatta da dio
tranne i titoli di coda che non si legge
un cazzo perché se magari mettevano un
po meno di border grazie perché mi è
piaciuto un sacco mi è piaciuto
veramente e vi sia piaciuto cosi il
momento mi piace anche ai socialisti
schiavi ci vediamo a un passo da ragazzi
dimenticavo sei morto
[Musica]